hey you guys
movie retrospective time yeah it's a
good one talking about a classic
yep this time around apocalypse
now probably one of the best movies ever
made
written by john millius yeah i don't
think anyone would argue with you on
that score
yeah written by john milius and directed
by
francis ford coppola it's
it's definitely the best vietnam war
movie oh easily
um i wouldn't say it was
totally accurate there's a it but in
certain ways
spiritually it was very accurate the
meaning behind it was pretty accurate
not everything you see in the movie like
for instance amelia said that a lot of
the stuff that
you see in the movie is not things that
troops actually did it was stuff that
they kind of wanted to do or wished they
could have done like for instance
water skiing behind the patrol boat yeah
yeah
that would be something you'd want to do
but
you really couldn't get away with that
you know um if you go back and look
at actual films of the missions and
photographs and everything
the army and the navy in theater was
usually
[ __ ] wired pretty tight and following
pretty tight rules they did have some
slip ups here there but
they're telling the the reason why
you're seeing all this stuff is because
they're telling
the story of heart of darkness
but what would happen if that was in
vietnam yeah pretty much so it's based
around another story
and uh milius
uh he was friends with veterans of this
war if milius himself wanted to join he
wanted to go to vietnam but he couldn't
because he had asthma
uh he wanted to be a pilot he wanted to
be a navy pilot
um he also kind of wanted to go in the
entry too a lot of his friends were in
the infantry i thought he wanted to join
the marines i thought he said he joined
the marines
well okay he might have might have been
talking about a marine pilot he was
talking about landing on aircraft yeah
so it may have been a marine pilot all
right but um
yeah and a lot of guys that worked on
this movie were special forces veterans
and vietnam veterans so
it is kind of an informed movie but
they're telling another story that
originally didn't happen in vietnam
from a book called heart of darkness
philosophically the movie's a
masterpiece
yes there's a lot of stuff in the movie
that has
other meanings or has spiritual meanings
uh it's very much
kind of an eastern philosophy based
movie in the same way that conan was
a lot of stuff that happens in this
movie also happens in conan
willard is kind of the conan figure of
this story
and colonel kurtz is basically false of
doom it's just a different
interpretation of thulson doom if you
know those movies
but that but it's kind of
retold for in in in the form of heart of
darkness which you know maybe you might
want to get into that part
yeah so where the kind of colonel for
this came from john milius uh
obviously who also wrote conan and you
know he wrote red dawn like a bunch of
other movies
dirty harry too uh yeah i think he did
the first two dirty harry movies if i
remember it correctly so he was still a
film student
oh i forgot to mention though oh we
always forget this one
jeremiah johnson yeah that's right
and there's a and there's a lot of
jeremiah johnson
in apocalypse now too a lot of the same
kind of things about
surviving in the wild and becoming part
of the wild and becoming a wild animal
that's really what johnson would but
then you find humanity in being a wild
animal
and an honor in it that's that's that
didn't mean to interrupt but i
had to throw in jeremiah johnson because
everybody forgets that one yeah
because it was like so early on you know
yeah
um yeah so he was still a student and uh
as you mentioned he
actually had wanted to go to vietnam but
they wouldn't let him because he had
asthma
and he says that he became intrigued
by one of his professors
saying that you know nobody's done a
good adaptation
of joseph conrad's heart of darkness and
so he kind of took that as a challenge
um and he
decided he was going to take the story
which was originally written in 1899
and transpose it to the vietnam war but
stay with the same kind of themes
um if you could and the interesting
thing too i was reading an interview
with him i think it was with empire
magazine from a few years ago
and he said that he had read um heart of
darkness
in school uh which i did as well and um
he said when he decided to do
like a vietnam specific version of it he
almost was like oh i gotta read the book
again and then he's like you know what
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna read the
book again because i want it to be
like heart of darkness as if i had
dreamed it and it was said in vietnam
um and it's interesting because he
actually did
remember like a great deal of the story
if you don't know heart of darkness is
actually
set it's not even it doesn't have
anything to do with the military really
it just has to do with
a bunch of dudes who work for a company
that
uh you know that does ivory and it's
basically a dude and a crew like going
upriver on the congo
looking for this dude kurtz who's kind
of like
um you know this this big ivory trader
but who has gone native and has um you
know gone savage
and uh has kind of like all these tribal
people like that sort of see him as a
demigod
so the fact that milius remembered that
much of the story that he was able to
transpose it because yes
apocalypse now is a lot different than
heart of darkness
but not by much i mean it's really kind
of
the same meaning it's the same meaning
and and honestly i think another thing
that milia said too that i thought was
really interesting was that
uh both heart of darkness and apocalypse
now are essentially
sort of like the classic descent into
the underworld story
like the odyssey or dante's inferno or
something like that
i think john milius even said he
compared the character of
colonel kilgore lieutenant colonel
kilgore in the movie to the cyclops
and uh the playboy bunnies to the sirens
and um
you know he's like the the one scene
toward the end
where they're kind of going through like
that bridge like right before they get
to kurtz's compound or whatever
and all those uh soldiers are in the
water like swimming toward them like you
know save us take us with you and all
this other kind of stuff
they took he took that like specifically
from
uh from uh dante's inferno that's
that imagery now the interesting thing
though was that even though john millius
did write the screenplay francis ford
coppola
changed it a lot from the original and
really
kind of um flew by the seat of his pants
he was kind of almost making it up as he
went along
like he had the screenplay but he
changed a bunch of [ __ ] um i've seen
some stuff that
said that really only 20 of melisa's
screenplay was left in the final movie
because so much of it was coppola like
rewriting it
yeah um and very famously he was just
kind of
i mean if you if you see and i kind of
want to get into this in a little bit
but if you see there was a documentary
that came out of the 90s uh called
hearts of darkness of filmmakers
apocalypse
this i can't even believe that this
movie came out the masterpiece that it
came out because filming it
was a cluster [ __ ] yeah the world's
biggest
filmmaking club i must mention that yeah
maybe only 20 percent
of milius's script was in there but
emilia's
totally approved of the two major edits
yeah yeah that were done which was the
the theatrical release and then the
redux edit he liked them both
he said that was it that's what he was
talking about it had a lot of the
elements that he was talking about in it
did you know that they did a final cut
in 2019 no i'd like to see that and
released it
it's basically the same as redux
except with 20 minutes taken out of it
okay you know what i mean
i i know what it is then because emilia
said
the scene where they hook up with the
playboy bunnies and trade for the fuel
to get some ass yeah he said really he
he liked he didn't like that being in
there yeah because it kind of
kind of foiled what what he wanted those
images to be which they were supposed to
be the sirens and the sirens were
unattainable
yeah you said that guys that he knew in
vietnam that were there
went through uso shows and of course i
you know i went to the u.s
uso shows too they just
they didn't when you had these ufo uso
shows it was just girls dancing and
and bands and you were happy to see
girls from home that's all it was um
the idea of bum rush in the show that
didn't actually
happen in reality reality and most of
the guys that were there according to
milius they do
they didn't really that didn't really
cross their minds too much but then
after azeroth was like
what if we just ran up there and grabbed
those girls so emilia's put that in
there millie's put a lot of stuff
of what if we just did that what if i
actually just
said [ __ ] it and decided to surf or [ __ ]
it i'm gonna go ahead and
see you know uh so it's kind of an
element of fantasy you know i'm i'm
gonna ski behind the patrol boat
yeah they would never allow you to do
that the ship was too dangerous you know
now the surfing element all that [ __ ]
makes sense when you hear what milius
was talking about
remember the charlie don't surf though
yeah yeah
a lot of that had to do with uh ariel
sharon
okay during the uh arab israeli war i
believe what was called
what the
israel invaded egypt and whipped ass
on a bunch of egyptian tanks and ariel
sharon
went down by the river and started
skewing some fish
and was looking at the guys that were
with him and says we're eating their
fish
yeah and that's what they even mentioned
that on the uh wikipedia yeah
we're eating we're eating their
well that kilgore was kind of in a way
based on ariel sharon you know
we're surfing their waves yeah that's
what that that's where a lot of that
stuff comes from
it's um you're going to see a lot of
different interpretations of
what all this stuff means and how you're
supposed to feel about it
when you understand john millions john
millions he'll straight up tell you
he is very warlike he doesn't try to
moralize war or say it's a good thing
he's just saying it's a
it's a transformative experience
and that it's kind of like a rite of
passage
part of personal development and you're
supposed to conquer it and get beyond it
he's very much in the nichian nietzsche
in nietzsche's philosophy which is very
kind of
eastern it's a german interpretation of
eastern philosophy
that good and evil are a single act in a
way that creation and destruction are a
single act
it's yin and yang and which is in a way
when you kind of think about it's almost
kind of sado masochistic
you don't know pleasure until you
understand pain that's kind of the main
thing you know you don't know peace
until you know war
you're supposed to get beyond it and
that's
and the story's written in that way it's
not really an anti-war story in the way
you would think it was
but it was kind of an anti-vietnam
conflict
story because it was kind of corrupt and
it wasn't pure
it was a fake conflict that was very
civilized
when you strip away the civilization off
of it what it really should have been is
something primal
a tribal struggle between tribes and
that's what kurt was fighting
and it was unacceptable to i guess you
could say the white man's army
all that's in there yeah that definitely
isn't
that's that's it and milius is kind of
condemning
western corporate warfare that it's
that their heart is not in it it's just
well then it's dishonest
it's dishonest it's about kickbacks you
got guys in washington
you elected the leaders in washington
getting kickbacks
from corporations because they gave them
the contracts that fuel
these things and and then the army's in
on it at the pentagon level
because of course you now there's a
chance for advancement up through the
ranks and bonuses
and you know everybody's making money
and uh it's not good because now you're
drafting poor guys and sending them out
there and yeah
they're meat grinder using them as bait
yeah basically
to try to find the enemy because the
enemy really doesn't want to fight you
like this the main problem of vietnam
was because it was being fought in a
corporate fashion
no war was declared they're just sending
these guys into the middle of a civil
war between vietnamese
and then the vietcong was something that
we kind of created years before to get
rid of the french
it was just some which they actually
mentioned if you see the redux version
there's a like an extended scene in
there where they
where they go and there's these you know
the the french
you know that they've been there for
like a really long time they have a
mansion and they have a whole discussion
about that
yeah i think that's the the weird thing
is that
scene it's probably the most con because
some people are like ah it kind of drags
the plot down it didn't mean
the history what the [ __ ] i think it
kind of gives the history i can see
i can understand how people say oh it
drags the movie down and blah blah blah
but what they did was it's not in the
theatrical cut
the whole thing is in redux which is the
longest version
and then in the final cut which um
which francis ford coppola did for the
40th anniversary which came out last
uh last year like 2019 and like ran
around in theaters and stuff
um he actually left it in there but he
shortened it
yeah and he took out the the playboy
bunny the second playboy bunny
thing yeah the scene as well i kind of
liked that in there though
i thought i thought i did too because it
was showing that it showed that
everything was kind of corrupt and it
showed a different side to willard
that willard was the scoundrel yeah
that he was there was very much willard
was very much kind of
uh a figure of kind of dualism
and in the longer edit when they're when
he's hanging out with the french colony
the conversation turns to politics and
the history of vietnam
and it turns out it's an
opportunity to show the audience that
willard doesn't really know the history
of the war he's just fighting it
yeah okay um he's just doing what he's
told to do
willard is like a perfect example of
ptsd i guess you could say uh he's a
complicated character
he's addicted to the war he likes it
he's waiting for another mission
because that's where he's getting his
fix from
um he's not rationalizing it until later
on as
as the story until he meets kurtz he's
kind of figuring it all out
um he's a good character uh and he does
a lot of stuff that
like steals kilgore's surfboard which
that got cut off
of the actual release and that was great
kilgore
sending the helicopters i will not harm
you please just feed
the board it's just hilarious well it
just kind of showed where kilgore's like
uh priorities were yeah
yeah well what what what what they're
trying to
what what what milius is trying to do
there he's trying to humanize
um kilgore in a way kilgore is a perfect
war machine he's just cut out for this
[ __ ]
he loves it all right mortars land
around him he doesn't even give a [ __ ]
he's going he's taking care of his men
he's war daddy you know it's kind of
he's kind of like um uh what's his name
from fury road kind of like
uh yeah yeah i know we're talking what
was that guy's name in morton's show
yeah
okay but he loves it but it also turns
out
he's just a regular guy he likes surfing
too and he's going to deny
and he's going to surf the enemy's waves
that's a
yeah he's got his own surfboard it's
hard to get a surfboard there
and then he put what
willard uses the fact that he's got a
famous surfer with him
to get kilgore to take his boat to a
certain location to get him to a certain
location
so it was kind of a he's tempting the
cyclops like you said
yeah and in the end just to be hey man
you better
he's gonna make you surf you know
because he's making his guys surf you
know in the mortar fire
it's hilarious and uh
willard steals his [ __ ] surfboard
just as a trophy
yeah to take to take what kills i liked
that scene i like that i know it's not
in the theatrical cut
but yeah it showed you that that it it
added another dimension
to uh to uh to willard
willard was fighting the war and he felt
he he felt he was at risk
but he was getting high off that risk
yeah he's seeing kilgore and he's just
loving it and kilgore doesn't even see
the risk
so you know what i mean because there's
no risk for kill gourd in the kilgore's
mind
yeah so he's gonna [ __ ] kind of
emasculate him i'm gonna take his
i'm gonna take his board because you
know because that's one that's the only
thing he cared about that was the only
thing that he could threaten so he
threatened the board yeah
because he knew that that like that that
was something that was his weakness yeah
was the
day on board because war wasn't his
weakness yeah because he just totally
didn't give a [ __ ] no like he said it's
like mortar fire going by his arm like
right behind him he didn't even flinch
he's like yeah whatever his voice how
you feeling i'm feeling like a real
killer sir yeah
yeah yeah you feel like a mean
[ __ ] yeah i feel like a mean
[ __ ] yeah
yeah so he was he actually you know
you know in case you guys don't know me
i'm [ __ ] ex airborne x hundred first
airborne division first in the 506 and
first in three two seven
so those air assault operations they
were calling amerimobile back then but
air assault operations what i did i was
infantry in air assault entry
so no when you go to war that kind of
that style of warfare which is now
actually obsolete but in that style of
warfare
kilgore is who you want is your
commander that's what you want
you don't want any shrinking violet
wallflower top commander you want
that because that guy's probably more
more
liable to get you home because usually
he's just
kind of like maximum aggression and
maximum
expertise and you know he was doing his
duties getting evacuating his wounded he
had the priorities right but it wasn't
stressing him out at all
he was loving it yes he was just having
a great time
one day this war's gonna end and then he
went down oh [ __ ]
bummer then what am i gonna do yeah
because that's where he belonged
yeah and he i mean and he's the one
obviously the probably the most famous
line of the movie i love the smell of
napalm in the morning yeah it's like
victory but we didn't find a single body
not one thing and that was actually
typical yeah
for the theater and then they try to
they call in f
basically all right let me give you guys
a background
why vietnam sucked for the infantry
point of view and on the ground
they're telling you that you have to go
out there and win this war
so you go out on patrol you don't see
anybody nothing happens
so who so who is the enemy you're not
sure you know what i mean you had
it was civilians yeah nowadays you'd
call it anti-terror
in a way that's how they would label it
like anti-terrorist activity
so you had to get the enemy to shoot you
so you had to do things to get them to
open up on you and then one but the
thing is is that
you do that by going into their
territories and just walking around
waiting to be shot
yeah and then once you got shot or what
some of your guys in your unit got shot
you then called in air strikes on them
all right well your chain of command for
your air force and the army is demanding
results you had how many people did you
kill this week
okay so you're going out of the bushes
to see who got bombed and you say
uh we think we found two
you know according to the pieces there
may be two here the guys in the jets
going okay then we killed them they got
no no
we took casualties we were on the ground
we killed them so they were fighting
over the kills
they say [ __ ] it let's just say that we
killed four
and the planes killed four so a total of
eight were killed
and there was only enough pieces for two
people the rest of them got away
yeah so a lot of times when you looked
it it was all it was all but it's called
by the numbers doing things by the
numbers
all right and they were running it like
a corporation you had x amount of guys
with x amount of ammunition x amount of
food
and x amount of people killed in x
amount of time and jam that you're not
doing good you're not going to get your
promotion
so everyone was being pushed like they
were running mcdonald's
yeah mcdonald's of death how many
burgers did you sell
you can't win a war that way it's more
artistic
and and it's more you have to find these
p it's social
you know what i mean it's a social
problem it couldn't be solved
and in that in the kurtz
when at the end kurtz reads him the time
magazine
thing right reads it to willard
and it was all a bunch of lies about how
effective
the war was the war wasn't effective at
all
nothing they knew there was a certain
amount of enemy out there and they were
claiming that they had killed all these
enemy
and that oh so we must be winning no
those numbers were all lies because
people had lied about how many people
they killed
the casualty numbers the official
casualty numbers
for enemy nva or kia
and and and vietcong kia it was all lies
it was inflated probably
by eight times at least because
everybody
had to divide it up yeah you had to
invent stuff to get credit
if not your commanders wouldn't get
promoted so they'd help you lie
so that was that that's that's what they
were talking about you know
the [ __ ] piled up so high in vietnam
you need wings to stay above it
well like i said i think that's what
contributes to making this easily the
best vietnam movie because
it just it highlights the sort of
madness and absurdity
yeah and all of the [ __ ] that was
going on behind it and it also kind of
um it also kind of made a statement
about like all these kind of poor people
that were there just kind of like
like you said going into this meat
grinder these kids yeah yeah
and it was so somebody in washington dc
or somebody in the pentagon could
buy a house they throw in their draft
and these kids and put them in this
situation
and that report that time magazine said
in the movie you know curtis was talking
about
that maybe or i think it was the time
magazine thing
said that maybe they should shift into
like fewer
men of higher but of higher quality
which is eventually what it went to yeah
because
the problems in vietnam and
or were the same as the problems
everywhere else you couldn't fix these
problems
with tanks and helicopters and machine
guns said that wouldn't do it
it had to be done at small scale
man-to-man and it had to be the right
people you know i mean arresting or
killing the right people
or but what was funny is that the whole
object of this [ __ ] experiment in
vietnam which is what it was it was not
a war
no war was ever declared the problem
with it
was that the united
the the american machine never had any
intention of winning it
winning it in quotes never it was just
to try out to try out new weaponry to
get your army trained up into
career advancement that's really what
what they did it for
yeah ridiculous yeah but
the way they thought back then was very
different they're like well we'll get
we'll figure out which weapons actually
work and what kind of men work and how
to run an army in there we'll use this
as a big training field
and then i'll get a new house and i'll
get all these contracts and make money
i'll get re-elected
that was what they were thinking do you
know that had anything to do with
solving vietnam's problems or anything
they didn't care about that
yeah of course not no i mean uh did you
know that
um for this movie uh they actually
approached
obviously the us army is like hey can we
borrow your [ __ ] for the movie
and uh donald rumsfeld was like no
because the movie's anti-vietnam so
we're not gonna let you
use our [ __ ] yeah so they ended up
having to go to [ __ ] ferdinand marcos
in the philippines because that's
mostly where they shot this okay um and
they just had to
they said it was like [ __ ] crazy
because i want to get a little bit into
like the production of this because like
i said it was [ __ ] crazy and how
such a masterpiece came out of this
[ __ ] is just like
a miracle for the ages but so they had
to borrow
helicopters and [ __ ] from the philip you
know
from the filipinos and they had to like
repaint them with american
[ __ ] and then sometimes they'd be
filming in the day and then ferdinand
marcus be like hey um i need my
helicopters back because we got like
some insurrection [ __ ]
going on over here and it's like
sometimes they didn't have time to like
repaint the [ __ ] so they still had like
american stars on them and [ __ ] like
that
and they had to go they just like a
ridiculous situation the higher meaning
of the movie in terms of an
anti-vietnam thing if that's the way you
wanted to interpret it which it was
okay i wouldn't say it was anti-war in
general
just kind of an anti-vietnam
anti-vietnam there's anti-vietnam
because
the style the style of warfare
that was being used in the movie and
also in vietnam
was already obsolete by the time all the
shit's happening it didn't work
it didn't work and it's just all those
people died for nothing yeah it didn't
work
it couldn't work yeah kurtz's way of
doing it would have worked was the
tribal way
it was working that's and they and part
of the reason why they wanted kurtz dead
is because kurtz could have exposed the
scam
and and they didn't believe that war
should be savage it should like a savage
tribal conflict
but that's what it was anyway kurt was
just getting to the heart of the matter
the heart of darkness
it was it's a savage tribal war yeah
like
people yeah like it was almost kind of
like his conflict was
you know with the higher ups the high
that we're trying to make it seem like
they're almost trying to like sanitize
they're trying to make it seem civilized
and trying to make it seem civilized
that's not what it was yeah but so okay
so very famously like i said simelius
wrote the screenplay and it took like a
long time originally
uh i don't know if you guys know this
but george lucas was supposed to direct
this [ __ ]
um but it ended up taking so long
and george lucas went off to do star
wars famously so he didn't really do it
what's that
george lucas's friendship with john
milius
resulted in the star wars that you know
yeah all the stuff about
the force the light side the dark side
and everything
that's all the influence of john
milius's kind of
eastern slash germanic
philosophies that he was into which
that's what made that star wars work so
you can kind of credit
milius for the success of the idea of
star wars well the thing about john
millius was he
is really into like these kind of
mythic yeah um like i said so
you know like the odyssey or joseph
campbell you know joseph campbell's like
yeah the golden bow the fisher king like
all that kind of stuff
so he's very into like these very
mythical stories that have been around
for thousands and thousands of years in
different iterations
so i think that's the reason why a lot
of his stuff works so well because it
has
it has that kind of mythical uh
underpinning
to it uh which this does as well so
all right so so that had kind of been
going around like i said george lucas
was supposed to direct it
and then uh all that ended up happening
and then francis ford coppola uh decided
to do it now
initially the shoot for this was only
supposed to take i believe
five months they were like i said they
were going to shoot in the philippines
very famously because of all of these
horrible things that happened
this ended up taking more than a year
to shoot they had problems like
uh a [ __ ] typhoon came through and
blew away all the sets including the one
that all the playboy bunnies were
dancing on
and they had to rebuild the whole thing
that i think they were that was like
eight weeks or something like that that
they were set back with that
so the character of willard was actually
offered to
several actors um i think the first
choice was steve mcqueen
uh but he said no because he's like i
don't want to be out of the country that
long
yeah yeah so uh a lot of people like
george lucas he made all that money from
um
from uh what was that america uh what is
it american graffiti american graffiti
he made all that money and got rich and
he's like i don't want to go to
philippines too many bugs
yeah well i think that rains all the
time yeah i think that kind of happened
with um a lot of and i mean even back
then like you know the the shoot was
only supposed to be
you know 14 weeks or whatever it was
supposed to be to start with so
i guess all those people were kind of
vindicated after like the [ __ ] shoot
took so much longer and like went way
over budget and it was like a huge
nightmare it was worth it though but uh
yeah well
happily um but yeah so steve mcqueen was
the first choice several other actors
uh were were asked and they mostly
turned it down for the same reason
now the guy that was originally supposed
to play willard was
harvey keitel yeah and he actually did
uh
i think he was there for two or three
weeks shooting and what ended up
happening was that francis ford coppola
he wanted the character of willard to be
kind of like
a passive observer and he said that
i didn't i harvey keitel couldn't really
play that
he seemed like it he was too i don't
know it's like he was just too intense
he was too
so it's kind of like so he kind of
kicked him off the chute and then they
ended up getting martin sheen
now interestingly i saw something about
this earlier today
that the opening scene with martin sheen
in the hotel room and he's just like
losing his [ __ ] like doing all the weird
dancing and like punching the mirror and
everything
um you know because he's kind of finding
his own heart of darkness i suppose
so basically what they did they're like
we shot that on martin sheen's birthday
and he's like well i'm gonna get drunk
and they said yeah get [ __ ]
up yeah so when you see that [ __ ] he's
completely shit-faced he actually did
punch the mirror and broke his hand
um they tried to stop it and he said no
no i got to keep going so he was just
like working through some [ __ ]
like in that so he is completely that is
like not even acting
um and also very famously as the shoot
went on
everybody was like i think francis ford
coppola lost like 40 pounds or something
because
it was a lot of his own money on the
line he couldn't get enough money to do
what he wanted to do
so he basically put his house and his
winery and i think one of his car
like some of his cars and [ __ ] like that
he gave them to
chase bank for collateral and was
basically like you know i need you know
30 million more dollars i need this that
the other thing
so it's like if this movie was not a
success he was ruined
um he wouldn't have a house his wine
would be everything would be gone he'd
be [ __ ] broke
so that was very stressful um a lot of
people said yeah he threatened to kill
himself like at least three times on the
[ __ ] set he lost all this weight
martin sheen had a near fatal heart
attack even though he was only 36 years
old
um just from the [ __ ] stress of
all of the [ __ ] that was going on and
like i said they the movie was almost
kind of like they had
john millie's script but francis ford
coppola kind of had his own thing
like what he wanted to do with it too so
he didn't really
i don't even think he had an end you
know what i mean they shot
i think it was something like 1.5
million feet of footage or something
like that
he they just shot like [ __ ] an
unbelievable amount of footage that they
shot
and it ended up taking four people and
two years
to edit it into some kind of coherent
form
and even when they first showed it i
think they first showed at the cannes
film festival and it wasn't even done
it was like a three hour cut and
i think that francis ford coppola i mean
at least according to milius like an
interview that i read with him he said
francis ford coppola the whole time
thought he was making a piece of [ __ ]
and he thought that it was just gonna
like
it's one of the best movies financially
ruin him but yeah
and haven't been in a bunch of air
assaults telling you
that the air assault scene that looked
real to me
i think that that really did look like
the interiors of uh ones hueys and
little birds flying around i mean
that's where it fit that's why it felt
it looked like those those camera shots
were taken from inside flying choppers
yeah i mean i don't i don't really get
any sense of anything being [ __ ]
like all of the [ __ ] in this now some of
this stuff that's real like um
like when they kill that uh caribou or
whatever it is at the end
uh that is real yeah that was just a
water buffalo
or water yeah i think it's a water
buffalo yeah you're right that was some
kind of tribal thing though
it was ceremony they ate that yeah and
that's how they got around
it's just a halal slaughter i guess yeah
that's how they got around the animal
cruelty laws because they said well
you know that was the tribal they would
they eat it afterward and it's like
that's what they would have done
so they just like filmed it for the
movie let me talk about some of the uh
the uh let me talk about willard okay
all right i heard some people
saying that willard was [ __ ] special
forces in the movie
and i kind of thought that at first the
first
couple times that i saw it because he's
wearing tiger stripe and that was
uniforms that were pretty much issued to
special forces
but if you look at his uniform he's
actually 173rd airborne and he's an
airborne ranger
uh he just happens that's it that was
his combat patch was 173rd
but he was working for mac uh
mac v sog which was like a special op
combined special operations group made
up of
all branches of the us military
all branches of the south vietnam
military
and the intelligence agencies so it was
kind of like
kind of like a a combined
high talent rock group in a way
of military units so he wasn't special
forces
um he wouldn't have an sf tab
and in one of the deleted scenes or a
part of the deleted scenes where he's
take
accepting the mission from the general
to go out and kill kurtz
the general asks him what he thinks of
special forces
and he says i've worked with them
they're they're pretty good he says
they're good
um and then the guy kind of looks a
little uneasy
and the reason why he's asking that that
was cut out reason why he's asking
that's because he's
asking him to kill a special forces
cartel
yep so he doesn't want to send a guy on
the mission that is
kind of idolizes anything special forces
and then some stuff some some glances
are going
some meaningful glances are happening
between the general and this
cia guy
and it has to do with this what do you
think of special forces
and they're kind of unspoke the unspoken
thing
is is that the army brass is not
trust in special forces that they're
kind of i guess going native
that's what the what it seems to be that
they're worried about
at this time special forces was
kind of a a newish thing you know was
i guess one of their first wars um it
had come out of a world war ii
group um max sogg was kind of like with
the oss
i guess you could say they did things
things that could have been illegal like
assassinate
people on your own side because you
found out they were double dealing but
you don't want that information out so
you just kill them
that kind of stuff yeah and it's
civilians killing civilians
maybe friendly civilians that are double
dealing
with the enemy so there has to be a way
taking care of these problems used to be
oss
what it had what ended up happening in
vietnam is it a lot of it was
some of it was mac v sog was doing kind
of what oss did
uh but special forces was running a lot
of basically kind of like
long-range reconnaissance patrol stuff
that involved ambushes
and training arvind troops which are
south of vietnamese troops they were
making south vietnamese rangers and [ __ ]
and in this context of this story
they're kind of showing you that the us
army might be kind of
not trusting these special forces guys
that they're out there too deep in a
general
jungle for too long that they're finding
out too much and they're
they're going rogue in fact incur
in kurtz's files it shows that he did a
rogue operation
that was very successful and had it and
had the news not found out about it they
would have busted his ass down but the
news found out about it
first so the army had to approve
this up this unapproved operation that
he did that resulted in
wiping out a bunch of enemy people
remember that
yeah he was reading that in the file so
they're telling you in the story that
special forces wasn't being real trusted
because they were kind of finding out
how to win a war
and the the pentagon really had no
intents of winning the war especially
the way they would wanted to do it
because their way was a little too
efficient and they would have missed out
on all that contract money
so there's a bunch of different ways
that you can look into that yeah
can we talk a little bit about how the
end of this movie
is very similar to the end of conan yes
because it's pretty much the same ending
now interestingly
i think there have been rumors going
around that oh it's you know oh it has
five different endings it doesn't really
um i think that basically coppola
he couldn't decide like when they were
shooting it he didn't really have an
ending in mind he's basically like it's
either gonna end
the way that it ends which is that
um you know willard goes he kills kurtz
he essentially takes over his role like
you know he from conrad's point of view
he takes the heart of darkness
um but then he kind of goes down and
takes lance who is the only remaining
member of
of the team and kind of leads him back
to the thing and they don't do the air
strike
he's like so we're either gonna end it
like that or we're gonna do the air
strike where they called in the air
strike which was
the code word was almighty and just
wipes everybody out in uh kurtz's
compound
um so what was interesting though was
that
and i didn't actually notice this and we
were watching it because we watched the
redux version i've seen the theatrical
version a long time ago and we watched
the redux version for this
um what is interesting is that one this
movie does not have
credits uh when they i mean that's how
coppola wanted it and he's like
basically when it first
kind of made the rounds he had it almost
like a theater program where he had like
the whole cast and crew like printed out
like on a thing that they would give to
you so he wouldn't have to put credits
in there
um but then later they were like no you
kind of need to put some credits on
there
so he put the credits on the end but he
put the credits over footage of
one of the napalm strikes just because
he liked the footage
but then he realized that people thought
that the napalm strike was
the airstrike coming and wiping out
kurtz's compound and he's like and
that's not how i wanted the movie to end
people were like misinterpreted he's
like i just thought the footage was cool
and i just so i just put the credits
like over that but everybody thought oh
[ __ ] they blew everything up
but that's not how the movie was
supposed to end the movie is supposed to
end essentially by
um you know as you said it was kind of
like
milius even said it's kind of like the
fisher king story where
willard comes he kills the king kurtz
and you know takes his [ __ ] or takes
over his power takes over the heart of
darkness as uh
conrad would say everybody in kurtz's
thing kind of bows down to him
um but he essentially doesn't want it
yeah it's the same things in conan yeah
all right conan cuts off dulce dum's
head with his father's broken sword
all right after he's figured out the
[ __ ] riddle of steel at the meeting
of the riddle of steel
the cult members all kneel to him
because in a
in more ancient primitive societies if
you killed the king he became the king
yeah that's mike made right yeah okay so
he killed dulce dune proving that he was
more powerful than those of doom all the
cult members
kneel evidently they lose their faith he
dismisses them they all
walk off he goes down to the end of the
[ __ ] temple and sits there like
like nietzsche's the thinker and thinks
about
dulcin doom's power and decides
not to not to uh not to accept that
power that he's going to take a
different path he goes beyond it
yeah beyond the temptation and then he
takes
the the princess that he was hired to
rescue
takes her by the hand and they walk off
together and she was waiting for him to
make the decision
to maybe become the new lord and they're
kind of a
male and female opposites but they're
kind of recognizing that they're kind of
a part of the same system
yin and yang you know male and female
it was you know the warrior and kind of
like
innocence i guess you could say well
that's redone again in apocalypse now
all willard
says i'm gonna i'm gonna complete the
mission cuts off
uh cuts off kurtz's head uh
his kurtz's army being
you know basically tribal and primal
warriors recognize that as a legitimate
act of succession
they look to him for the leadership he
turns it down and he takes
lance this the surfer yeah all right who
is the only guy left he takes him
and they walk off by the hand and they
walk off together and don't call in the
air strikes no they didn't
now you say well wait a minute hold on
why the guy why lance if he
had been paying attention to the story
lance was a surfer who really didn't
belong in vietnam
he had just been drafted and through the
whole thing he did fight back but
through the whole thing he just kind of
looked at the war through like
the eyes of just wonder and innocence
yeah he'd just stand up in the middle of
the damn gunfight because he was on acid
watching it going wow
um he recognized when people were
playing with him like uh when they were
going down the
they were going down in the patrol boat
and the natives shot toy arrows at him
he just played back and put the arrows
he didn't shoot back at them
everybody else did yeah so he kind of
was kind of light-hearted and playful
and innocent about the whole thing and
it didn't
it didn't seem to affect him in the same
way as it and he was the guy that found
the puppy as well found the guy that
found the puppy and he wanted to go back
for the puppy it didn't um
he was able to kind of stay above it and
kind of maintain his innocence in a way
kind of was kind of like sending a child
to combat yeah he did come across as
very childlike
yeah and i think that and i think there
that you're right
he was kind of like the he was just
standing for a female the representation
of
or just innocence i think more anything
else innocence and he
if somebody who didn't belong there
didn't really deserve to be there in
terms of
they hadn't done anything wrong yeah
they were just kind of they were drafted
they're forced to go
yeah and and uh remember he spent a lot
of time just
amazed by it yeah he i mean and he was
real high most of the time yeah
as well right but that was part of it
i mean he didn't take it seriously he
got he stayed high through the whole
thing go wow yeah
wow this is a trip yeah because it's a
very very trippy movie it's a this is
one that i really really wish that i had
seen on the big screen
actually if i'd known that they had done
like the the version last
year back in 2019 where they re-release
it to theaters i would have gone
um because i've never got to see this on
the big screen and it must really be
something else
yeah because the you know the imagery of
it is just amazing
and it's been remastered and [ __ ] like
that now when they got to the camp they
killed chef because chef
chef said yeah i'll call him there it's
like i'll kill him myself i'll kill him
he was into he's just
got his head off yeah kurtz cut his head
off but they didn't even hurt
um lance because lance just walked
around like an innocent child
yeah wow you could see look at that
place yeah wow this is this
it's like he wasn't there it was like he
was watching something well he didn't
see him as a threat
and he just kind of like went along
whatever
yeah you know what i mean i think a lot
of draftees going through vietnam would
kind of like that
just kind of ride along with it remember
there was a lot of
veterans that that were were inspiring
milius and telling him stories so
yeah and i think these guys were were
based on stories
he said that the you know the story that
colonel kurtz tells about
the um about them coming and like
cutting off the kids arms yeah
like when they got vaccinated or
whatever milia said that he had a friend
that was in vietnam that had either done
that
or had seen it um but you know nobody
knows if it really did happen or not
because it was kind of an urban legend
there was a lot of legendary stories
they came out of vietnam a lot of dudes
lied about vietnam you had
serial killers lying yeah i was in
vietnam and a special force unit and i
just killed women
yeah and it turns out that dude was
never in [ __ ] service you know
they're just
there's a lot that's there's so much
there's so much mythologizing yeah
i mean my first sergeant first sergeant
richardson was did two tours of vietnam
and went up and down hamburger hill i
think two or three times in a 24-hour
period
and in his wallet had whole pictures of
his whole platoon dead on the damn
flight line
it was him and like five other guys in
this platoon that lived
and and we had squad leaders in my
time that were vietnam veterans and
they told us that actually that the ship
was run
very tightly it wasn't like a bunch of
rag bags and being wild men they were
under quite a bit of control yeah bad
[ __ ] happened
every now and then but um all in all it
was the discipline levels were pretty
high
which that's not what you're really
showing they didn't want to be high but
they were they were [ __ ]
disciplined was pretty brutal most of
the time
um now there may have been some places
where you know
unit cohesion broke down like you know
how they showed
the one unit where the the the commander
stepped on a land mine and a replacement
never came so everything was just going
to [ __ ] yeah
that wouldn't happen in real life the
commander be killed somebody else would
take over immediately and
they would send a new commander and yeah
the
the army was being the war was being
fought through a system of what was
called uh
firebases and they were tightly
controlled and they looked great they
looked real organized and
ship-shaped you know there were little
artillery firebases they were run
patrol bait patrols out of them and they
had little landing zones for choppers
and [ __ ] and they had all the amenities
and
but like i said i i think that you know
using
the lens of vietnam to tell the story
through yeah
um they're trying to make it more savage
it's not well and it's not so much
realistic as myth as mythic i mean he
wanted it to be
spiritually correct yeah he wanted it to
be kind of like like i said a descent
into the underworld so it's just like
the farther you went up the river
the worse it got the worse it got like
the more madness the more savagery the
more
you know so so every single stop they
made it just got like got worse and
worse and worse
and that was just kind of how and the
book is kind of like that
too now there's some more conan
references and conan lessons in there
too i don't know if you picked it up
um the uh what's his name chief phillips
the guy who
uh ran the boat yeah he kind of had he
he kind of had
a a special bond with clean yeah
played by a very very young lawrence
fishburne yeah you don't even recognize
so young i didn't even recognize him
because he was like
he was a kid and clean was clean was a
great
character very real there's there was a
lot of guys in service that when i was
never like clean
you know uh real young and looking to
his commander
uh for guidance and uh support you know
for in for safety there was definitely a
father-son type relationship
going on yeah between those two and then
when clean got [ __ ] waxed
like in uh phillips [ __ ] lost it
and um what ends up happening later
on it's kind of an explanation of why
phillips tried to kill kurtz in the very
end it's because phillips was really
trying to do his duty
he was trying to protect his crew he was
blaming all this on willard
they were he was forced to go on this
mission with willard
and willard really didn't know where
they were going he was he had to find
kurtz yeah so in his
dying moments uh
chief phillips says well if i'm going to
die i can kill
willard and it'll save the crew because
they'll just turn back and go home
yeah and that's that's why he was doing
that because he got hit by the arrow and
then he tried to pull
her down into the air onto the arrowhead
and that was his attempt to try to ke
trying to save the crew yeah
well because yeah he got totally like
[ __ ] he didn't you know they didn't
want to [ __ ] go on that match
and roped into they got roped into it
and they didn't really know where they
were going and essentially
they were going into cambodia which they
weren't really supposed to be doing yeah
there was no war in cambodia right that
was part of the thing that
you know part of the thing where there
wasn't supposedly
there wasn't a war in vietnam either it
was a police action no war was ever
declared they're fighting with
limited numbers this u.n sanctioned
police action slash forever war most of
the enemy
for safety we just went up into damn
laos and cambodia to hide because you
couldn't attack them there
right so they were safe there that i
didn't jump the border
well that's where all the good [ __ ] was
happening and evidently that's
where kurtz decided that's where he was
going to strike because that's where the
enemy was
yeah you know and he was using
tribal tactics against him which were
working
but that's not the situation the army
wanted
[Laughter]
but kurtz didn't care what the army
wanted he gave up his career as a
general
to join special forces which meant that
he would never get above colonel
he didn't want to be a general he wasn't
he wasn't kurtz was not in it
for career he was in it because he
wanted to be a warrior
yeah and he got it got what he wanted he
found out
yeah found the heart of darkness he
definitely didn't care if he lived or
died
and willard took him out he was a
modified version of thulsa doom
the difference was is that salsa doom
used his
ended up ended up maturing into a
warrior that
used his words and manipulation and
subversion
to get people to obey him through
you know the power of flesh yeah that's
what he called it
kurtz was like that except he used i
guess the power of direct
action and unconventional warfare well
you know having
heads and bodies all over terror yeah
you know he was just because that's what
works
yeah yeah to control everyone yep um but
yeah so
and oh and i forgot to mention too and
this is also a very famous story about
apocalypse now was that
when uh marlon brando arrived
to do his scenes he was also kind of
bitching about
because i think he got paid two or three
million dollars for this movie
and uh he arrived like a lot later
because he didn't have to shoot his
scenes until later
and in the book i don't know if you know
um
but kurtz is like a real real scrawny
dude um
and he was kind of scrawny in the movie
he doesn't get no no
no no no no i was thinking will it
willard i was gonna say he's definitely
yeah
yeah well he got a little fat didn't he
yeah well
yeah the thing about it and another
thing too is at the end of the book
nobody kills
curts he dies of a disease probably
but yeah i think it was malaria um but
yeah so
marlon brando shows up and he's like 300
pounds yeah
and francis ford coppola is like
flipping out he's like look your costume
doesn't fit now
it's like what the [ __ ] dude i thought
you're supposed to be like a special
forces lean and hungry type
that's what he kind of hired him for and
then he shows up and he says it's like
big
fat person i understand what happened
you know what happened to brando right
i've seen the photographs brando got
checked yeah i mean he looked [ __ ]
great in the years before this
which tells me he was on anabolic
steroids and then when he came off those
things man he had a tremendous
hormone crash yeah which he will get fat
as [ __ ] because your testosterone
production shuts down
they didn't know back then that you need
to jump on clomid
to get that t levels back up and i don't
think they knew much about
hormone [ __ ] therapy and replacement
but
they would just jump on steroids and
then just jump off like you could do
that
yeah no you'll get fat perfect real fat
which he did and like i said so he
showed up and it's
he was completely not prepared he hadn't
read the script
um i think they had to shut down for
nine days so so coppola could read the
script to him because he couldn't even
be bothered to read it himself
um and he just kept arguing about what
the character was gonna be like and blah
blah
until finally finally he read the
original book
one night and then he was like okay i'll
play the character like that like the
one in the book
um and uh also very famously him and
dennis hopper didn't get along
they actually hated each other and uh so
they were kind of they couldn't even be
even if they were in the same scene they
couldn't even like be the same they had
to shoot them at different times
and like do because they hated each
other so much
the thing is i kind of understand the
fat colonel kurtz
yeah because in the context of the of
this story
he was really no longer a special forces
commander
he was now basically a tribal warlord
yeah which he would have been sitting
around
thinking philosophy and they've been
feeding him and over feeding him yeah it
actually ended up
working it makes a little more sense and
then the way that they
he became a yeah and then the way that
that francis ford coppola ended up
shooting him
like mostly in shadow um just mostly his
face
and things like that i think they did
have a body double for some of the long
shots so he wouldn't look quite so big
like wearing him you know putting him in
black clothes and stuff
um i think it actually turned out for
the better because he almost
he comes across like a mythological
figure almost
because you can't really see him and
then like all the stuff that he's saying
like all this
like quoting t.s eliot and like all that
kind of stuff
well he was also saying all kinds of
stuff that was relevant that
if you kind of understood the way armies
are and what was happening in vietnam
some of his recordings and the messages
that he was sending out remember the
generals planning to look this is this
is the transmission we got from because
i watched a slug crawl across the edge
of a straight razor yeah it sounds
[ __ ] crazy
but it makes perfect he's talking about
the united states army and its armed
forces crawling across the straight
razor
of vietnam being cut yeah and destroyed
it's because it was a big slow
ungainly thing that
required a total it could not do what it
was supposed to do it required
pinpoint targeting of specific people
all right and lots of terror it had to
be something tribal and personal against
certain people
that that was the only way you were
gonna win
unquote vietnam but there was no way to
win vietnam
it was a social problem you cannot solve
that with military
force if you really looked at what the
problem was it was
landlords charging too high of a red
on rice farmers that's really what the
what it was about and it had the
trappings of communism and that's what
the people back in the united states
were told we were stopping the spread of
communism
no ho chi minh didn't give a [ __ ] about
communism he he went to us
first to ask us for support to help them
get the french out of there
yeah so he wanted to ally with us
because he allied with the only people
that
offered him any support and it was china
and a little bit russia
and they hated the chinese and that was
talked about in that damn
in that uh yeah with the french yeah
they never
really became communist per se they just
kind of had the
superficial trappings of it
so that was just that was just more of
what
willard was saying about the [ __ ]
would pile pileups so so high in
vietnam you need the wings to stay above
it it was mostly [ __ ]
yeah on both sides all sides and like i
said that's why
this is probably the best i don't think
there'll be a better vietnam movie made
just
because this really captured like you
said it captured the spiritual essence
yeah of the whole enterprise and we were
in there
supporting the guys that we that
supposedly should have been the good
guys which were kind of the more western
style
with christian influenced and capitalist
inspired that these were the guys we
really should have been
supporting and that was a corrupt ass
regime really bad to its people
so we were kind of fighting on the wrong
side of war just be
based on on on on
very shallow appearances of capitalism
and communism
but it gets back to the thing the
military industrial complex or the big
washington dc machine really didn't give
a [ __ ] about that place
it was just a project it was a means of
advancing their careers
they didn't care about it their heart
wasn't in it and the movie says that
yeah yeah and and like i said it really
kind of perfectly encapsulates
not only a period in time but like i
said i think that's why
apocalypse now is still considered one
of the best movies ever
not just the best war movies ever made
one of the best movies ever made period
yeah um you know and it got [ __ ] man it
got nominated for like
[ __ ] academy awards it got like it's
it's
topped the list i think the uh what's
that big list that's in the uk
like best movies ever it's like the top
of that one and it's just kind of like
and honestly um all three versions are
good because i was
watching something the other day and
people were like you know if i've never
seen it
which version should i watch because all
three of them are different
but and you know there's there's
arguments to be made that
that any of the three versions are good
but i don't know i i just feel like
i like redux because it it's everything
is in there
you know what i mean um and i i get i
totally get why some people would
not like it you know just because
there's or not like it as much as the
theatrical cut because i've seen some
people say oh they like the theatrical
cut better because it's like the pacing
is better or whatever
but i don't know i kind of like to see
the longer version with everything in it
yeah they're both good yeah and and like
i said the final cut
is essentially redux but with 20 minutes
taken out i think they take out the
second bunny scene they take out some of
the french stuff but not all of it
yeah you know they shorten that scene up
some some people have asked what's the
meaning
of the movie the meaning of this movie
is the same as the meaning of
conan which is that which does not kill
you makes you stronger
that's the one one of the messages the
other message is
that yeah that you're caught basically
on a quest to go
what nietzsche we got to call beyond
good and evil
what that means is is that giving up on
very superficial
value judgments of what happens in order
to fi what is happening in the world
in order to find what the truth is in
other words get rid of labels
that's it was those were the two main
themes yeah
yeah which like you said was a similar
to similar to conan
so you can almost watch these two movies
yeah like both masterpieces
if you like this movie watch conan one
don't worry about too
too much didn't it's not millions it's
more of a kids movie it's not a bad
movie it's just
not a great movie this one conan one and
jeremiah johnson and red dawn
similar yeah similar uh millius was not
typical dude not typical hollywood
especially for the time
okay um at this time in california
hollywood was a
very california ucla berkeley
film school um very california
young jewish guy very democrat
left kind of leaning emilius was that
too but not left more right he was very
contrary
he did if you told him right he would
say left he did not
like to go along with it which did not
make him a lot of friends in hollywood
the other yeah
what's this dude what is he a fascist do
you know is he a nazi why does he like
nietzsche that's german stuff
no it's just listen to milius there's a
lot of
uh he's he was a cool dude i liked him
he's an interesting very interesting guy
and uh he did he was jewish
in the aerial sharon way they're very
right-wing
but not political it was more spiritual
it was about
growth and and overcoming things and um
he liked the struggle and that's how he
thought well almost kind of
yeah like like you had to find like go
down into like the
the most darkest part of myself too he
would go on long
camping trips and hunting trips and
stuff up in i think oregon and stuff
and uh colorado yeah because he lives in
the wilderness yeah because he couldn't
go to the military so the next best
thing was to go on these
hunting expeditions living outdoors for
a long time
so you can suffer yeah because it's not
easy it's hard
and that's what makes you stronger so
i love everything about milius i totally
know he's talking about and i can back
up
most of what he believes in is
spiritually true maybe not factually but
spiritually it's true
yeah it's it's it's one way of doing
things
um it's the way i prefer to do things
yeah i mean it really like that it's
about preference i think
yeah and his stuff really does resonate
with you particularly but like i said
apocalypse now
i never heard anybody say anything bad
about this maybe to be honest
the reviews were a little bit mixed when
it first came out but
um hollywood guys didn't like it
evidently
well no what ended up happening was that
they were kind of like most people
you know we like roger ebert people like
that was like the [ __ ] masterpiece
um there were a couple that were kind of
like mixed reviews but then
i mean only like a year later people
were just like yeah it's a classic so
it didn't really take a really long time
before people recognize you can't
you can't it was a work of genius you
can't hide genius
you can't hide greatness it it comes it
starts to rise to the top over
especially over time
yeah yeah maybe people don't like it
when it's released but that shit's not
going to go anywhere if it's great over
time yeah
it just it took a lot because we talk a
lot about movies that you know like the
shining or the thing or something like
that
that you know didn't get real great
reviews at the time but then it took a
while and it found its audience
this one mostly same thing although like
i said most critics
recognize that it was genius from the
start um there were a few mixed reviews
but it
really seemed like the mixed reviews
just kind of went out the window like
a year or two later everybody recognized
it's the same with a lot of the
the same with a lot of the uh uh dino de
laurentiis movies like uh
flash gordon dune yeah
they at the time they came out you know
they they
actually uh conan one i think was that
was dino de laurentiis conan two was
also even though they were different
directors but when the when see like
dune one came out
it kind of flopped but in a way there's
a lot of greatness to that
movie even though it's very imperfect i
mean yeah
they're trying to tell a three-movie
story in one movie
and it's kind of moving a little faster
i mean we talked about that on the dunes
that it just seemed like it is possible
still visually
and just the score and just there's
something kind of religious about it
it's almost like something out of the
old testament
yeah yeah i like that movie still we'll
see what the remakes like
they say so far i've heard that the
first part of the reason me and i'm
excited about it yeah but um yeah
you can't go wrong with this one this is
a good movie yeah and i feel like this
is a movie
that probably everybody that's into film
should see it
yeah i mean because this is yeah
but this is pure filmmaking right here
you know what i mean and
it's it's just an amazing amazing film
yeah now here's nothing we're talking
about milius
um wasn't that the big lebowski his
friend was based upon john millius
yeah in the movie the big lebowski he's
got a vietnam veteran friend
played by what's that guy's name he was
[ __ ] uh yeah yeah i know you're done
yeah
they modeled that character after after
milius yeah
yeah and you if you see if you see uh
you see what do you call it interviews
with millions you can see exactly what
they're talking about
yeah but yeah it's good flick good flick
yeah i mean
it's a great flick like i said everybody
should see it and if you haven't seen it
go see it right now i mean it's like
seeped into the cultural consciousness
man
it's like all the [ __ ] [ __ ] about
charlie don't surf and
[ __ ] so there's so many lines from
this that are like so iconic so many
lines many situations that's been like
so parodied and everything like that
so i feel like if you haven't seen it
you really really should but yeah so
that will do it for this
uh extra long movie retrospective and uh
we'll see you on the next one bye
you